gérard jugnot bonsoir soit on va se
livrer à une petite interview première
fois c'est bon vous voulez bien
la première baffe
c'est pas la première mais je viens et
dont je me souviens c'est quand j'avais
fait une
blague à mon père qui venait de changer
la moquette il avait acheté une moquette
tout neuf c'est une grande grande
première et j'avais acheté une fausse
une fausse tâche d'encre une petite
bouteille d'encre mais quand mon père a
vu ça je n'en supprime terrible à
mirabeau
on s'était pas c'était c'est resté très
secret l'a pas su
que c'était une jeune fille sa planète
elle n'a jamais su je trouve quand même
le sait toujours quand et c'était à
royan j'avais fait les plans de toutain
toute la côte sauvage pour sam occupait
pour savoir si je l'emmenais où j'aurais
pu l'emmener au moment brassée en
cachette sans que ça paraisse donc
j'avais fait toute une topographie des
lieux on suit jamais serré première
expérience sexuelle
c'était en tunisie en un club de
vacances
qui n'était même pas méditerranéen
qu'une jeune fille que j'ai
pas forcément avoir très envie mais où
j'ai tellement tanné une chez eux elle a
accepté gentiment
premier pétard j'ai un souvenir vraiment
ils m'ont fait fumer du shit avec
lhermitte et clavier on avait été aux
états unis est en fait tiré là dessus
s'unir très forte ça devait être un des
premiers je crois que c'était un des
derniers parce que j'ai une seconde à
lui et c'était à saint louis missouri
souvient et d'un seul coup j'ai vu tous
les mecs sortir des bosquets avec des
fusils à canon scié et paul henry henry
est plurielle thèse d'un serveur est
sûre et vu une vraie panique donc non
c'est pas mon truc c'est ma première
expérience homosexuelle
on se tripoter dans les chiottes là-haut
lui seul mais bon c'était pas très
vraiment moi sexuelle c'était en a trop
on compterait défi et j'ai même
l'impression
première paillis alalalala pays quitté
plots m'a plus importante c'est une paye
de figuration qui était à marquer
artistes de complément ça mon père est
tombé à la renverse artistes de
complément c'était pour lui atroce
considéré que j'étais même pas un
artiste serti de complément aux
premiers millions d'anciens francs je
suis pas encore
premier procès
tu as pensé que j'ai fait pour contre
mon sosie
il utilise était mon image à des fins
commerciales qui me déplaisait
au revoir
tu connais nos amis absolument année sa
part a dit florent pagny vous connaissez
les synonymes ouais on pourrait dire
bien proportionné ouais un peu musclé
ouais un peu trop fort trapu voilà les
gars nous voilà ouais tu aurais préféré
ça brûle bah ça sera pour la prochaine
excuse moi je
suis très mal
garé ce mec c'est dingue qu'il met une
moustache on dirait jugnot ouais bah oui
lui ressemble c'est incroyable dis moi
pour l'instant c'est florent pagny
qu'avec les du baradé
tu connais d'interviews open dames
abeilles par le plus le mois le plus
justement par exemple ce qui te plaît le
plus dans le cinéma à savoir répond
ouais c'est toi l'invité à ce qui me
plaît le plus
washington plus au cinéma
ça il ya un côté club med c'est à dire
qu'on a une feuille de service on sait
ce qu'on doit faire tout organiser on
s'est vraiment géo donne de l'argent de
poche ou pour dîner le soir ça c'est
très agréable et un côté comme ça on est
pris en charge est ce qui te plaît le
moins enclines à main c'est la tante
enfin je peux dire ça pour vous
avec ce plus d'attendre la plus grande
joie de ta carrière or qu'est-ce que de
quoi qu'est ce que l'amour quand tu vois
ta carrière
bah c'est de continuer
continuer de faire ce métier mais ça
m'étonne toujours la plus grande
déception
c'est de ne pas avoir fait certains
films
travaillé avec des grands pourquoi fait
qu'ils sont disparus qui ont disparu
dans ce voyage aurait voulu le projet
avec de funès avec ventura tu es sont
partis ce à sa manière ouais bonne
réponse intelligente sensée et bien
sensible et riot toit plus gros coup de
fric
coup de fric 1 j'ai réalisé des pubs
pour le loto ouais tu dois laisser
gagner non non pas du tout mais comme
c'est plutôt bien payé la pub j'ai fait
beaucoup de pub pour le tournage et
guérir notre cas plus grosse perte
c'est ça les cheveux
ce que tu préfères en toi
le regard fait voir
il est bien ce que tu détestes en toi ah
bon
[Musique]
une tête qui est posée s'il n'y a pas eu
de coups
y a pas de coups donc il ya un double
menton prêt-à-porter donc ta plus belle
histoire d'amour c'est vous là est la
plus minable
basse et vous aussi
peut-être plus sexy en toi
les bras ouais
et deux mois c
est peut-être
ce que tu préfères de sex bomb ou
que tu quittes des gouttes dans le sac
l'époque
quand les poils tombe ah oui
il faut bien faire qui tient bien encore
fait ôter les feuilles de menthe qui
sera lancé
quand tu as voulu être artiste au front
ton père t'a dit tu finiras clochard oui
tu penses des fois quand j'ai fait mon
dernier film nuit
pour une halte à tulle est et dans le
cinéma oui il était content parce qu'il
m'a vu en cash à
gagner de l'argent non j'avais les
jetons mais mais je trouve que c'est
bien d'avoir les jetons et dans 20 ports
du doigt comment
tu préfère pas y penser avant maintenant
on va arrêter de se marrer parce qu'on
n'est pas là pour rigoler à mon cheval
garer ouais tu sais que c'est le jour
des morts aujourd'hui non bah ouais qui
ça je dis ça c'est de novembre ces
journées alors on va parler de choses un
peu plus grave si tu veux bien parce
qu'il faut qu'il y ait une dimension
rien dans une émission il faut qu'une
dimension émotions alors j'y allais
carrément comme tous les comiques au
fond gérard jugnot s'est pas franchement
gay tout bien sûr y'a pas de rire sans
tristesse tu dis toujours les gens
confondent les acteurs avec les
personnages qui jouent eux-mêmes les
personnages qu'on joue ils ont dit que
les emmerdes pour rire il faut qu'on est
con soit pertuis d'emmerdements tu as
déclaré c'est pas un secret qui était
vraiment neurasthénique toi non j'ai
chaque pied un jour ou une gt ça qui va
discuter chapier qui n'avaient pas
digéré
je
maniaco dépressif au soir et était mal
quand même oui j'étais sur le dos
tu parles de vertige d'exister je
voulais faire une séquence un peu triste
un peu tu vois et cessionnaires oui
nous avons écarté l'idée que les tours
ne connaissent pas le nom d'où vient
d'où vais jouer
quoi ça sert qu est-ce qu avant et
pourquoi la tva des choses comme ça la
mort tu es prêt ou pas bien sûr la mort
oui oui
l'existence mouais je fais des
cauchemars
et un cauchemar qui revient choses à moi
ouais c'est un cauchemar
mais non mais tu vas pas s'il rêve tu
aurais fait un cauchemar et tu te dis si
je me réveille pas je vais mourir tu le
fais ce cauchemar a ouï dire que tu le
fais ce que je vois et ce que les gens
qui ont fait des fiches et tout ce temps
j'ai pas besoin de gens vont fermer fier
je crois
la nuit oui c'est pareil vous dites
réveille en sueur ou 80 ans mais comme
tout le monde est ce qu elle pas un truc
est pire que mourir finalement c'est d'y
penser non s'est réveillée vivant dans
son cercueil oui je pense des fois ça
non pas de trous ça s'est passé beaucoup
de beaux coups de flippe rim la paix non
comme la zoophilie tout ça non
j'aime ça c'est bête je n'y pense pas il
pensait plus souvent bien non ici le
jour même est-ce que tu attachent de
l'importance à ce que les gens pensent
de toi ce n'est pas qu'ils pensent quoi
- une cabale de gens qui peuvent penser
ce qu'ils veulent donc chez mais les
gens que j'aime bien ça m'apporte bon on
va boire parce que bien entendu tu t'en
doutes on est allé avec une caméra dans
la rue on leur a demandé ce qu'il
pensait de toi mais avant de leur
demander ce qu'ils pensent et wall e
rallye 2 3 trucs un truc très objectif
treize costard de stars c'est de l'info
un spécial je crois qu'il a très mauvais
caractère vont bientôt courant que leur
soit il a une sale réputation c'est on
peut le dire une ordure tu passes un pas
un type odieux dit oui carrément ça vous
étonne ou pas du tout c'est ce qu'on en
dit comme je connais pas je sais pas si
c'est vrai au pain enfin pour moi c'est
pas leur dire vous promettra pour moi
c'est une ordure que vient de découvrir
qu'il touche le chômage sous 19
identités différentes à vous choque ou
pas
beaucoup mais monsieur que pensez-vous
de gérard jugnot lui sympa
découvrir qu'il touchait le chômage sous
29 identités différentes vous en pensez
quoi
neuf mois par mois
c'est scandaleux c'est tout
non ma chance ça ressemble au personnage
chaque mois ils touchent le chômage ce
59 identités différentes je pensais ce
contenu
ce sont 17 fois le chômage
on sait de source sûre que lors de ses
dernières vacances en espagne il a
abandonné son chien on attachant un
arbre ça vous choque ou pas si ça c'est
pas vrai ça vous choque vous qui les
violait son chien je suis pas au courant
si c'est vrai c'est dégueulasse mais je
suis pas au courant je peux vous dire je
vais pas accuser sans preuve clairement
je dirais ça dépend ça dépend des
sciences po sont ça dépend pour quoi il
l'a fait si ça intrigue passionnel ou
pastis et passionnel c'est pour avoir la
maison plutôt
essayer de vous violez vous vous diriez
quoi
je refusais enfin je le mot viol c'est
une atteinte à une personne non non 9h02
jugnot en plus c'est pas mon genre de
types variés vous faire violer par quel
genre de mec
blond aux yeux bleus est loin
pascal russell
dis moi tu as appris la sexualité dans
le larousse médical il paraît c'est pas
une honte tout le monde a fait
s'arranger pour à
ses débuts il ya plein de gens qui ont
appris la sexualité la hausse médicale
tous les toubibs lui à l'époque lui
c'était d'abord pas réduit août
s'étaient maquillés rien voilà très
bizarre quoi qu est ce qui avait alors
comme au japon il y avait dans le sexe
des hommes et des femmes il y avait cet
ego mairie et plus rien très inquiétant
dans le vide entre les bonnes et varié
avec des ventilateurs d'être enfin dans
le désert médical avec des coupes coupes
du peignage
3d tron plus à la
gente
féminine
est ce que tu as une sexualité normale
maintenant je joue des livres d'auteurs
oui
c'est halloween au statut répond par oui
ou par non ce n'est pas compliqué
si tu l'a trompée tu lui dirai oui ou
non oui tu dirais trop loin ce que je la
quitterais avant si je la trouve si je
n'aime plus tu regardes les cassettes
pornos
à l'événement oui non
ça m'est arrivé
de disette
de trois accords pour voir les choses
comme ça qui détaille top 5
c'est impressionnant
ça laisse rêveur ah oui c'est le temps
qu'ont brand
s'est déjà fait l'amour à plusieurs
n'ont jamais à plus de
2,7 une fois il ya 120 ans
et des commentaires et des s'était fait
ça c'est pas très bien
je suis pour soi c'est déjà utilisé des
instruments
les démonte pneu
les pinces à
jamais non loin du truc une tomberez sur
la place à faire une bouteille
de jack des expériences sado maso
s'est jamais fait fouetter par exemple
jamais envie non non non non non mais
c'est mal des foires sur le père express
des maladroits que dix mois toi
dit et confessé corps pour la dernière
fois oriane pays avant mais tu t'es
qu'on fait c'est déjà un but parce que
j'ai encore la paroisse de communes ici
non ah ouais ça faisait du bien
tu pas désagréable parce qu'on sortait
être allégée comme après après
résultats d'analysés qu'en penser qu'on
est séronégatif
tibia sensation oui on y va j'avais fait
exactement la même sensation merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dis moi j'ai rien fait a été dur à vivre
pendant tout ce temps d'être le beauf de
service
pour te sérieusement j'ai joué les
personnages qui était un petit peu
caricaturaux il
une tête de français c'est vrai j'avais
une tête de français
j'essaie de moustache là
je m'étais fait poussé par le service
militaire jeter dans l'eau parce que là
je t'ai pas passée inaperçue puis
maintenant je passais plus du tout une à
bercy ça te fait souffrir de devoir en
franche meilleur à l'heure tous les
soirs dans les arènes de l'info quand
même plus
oui sauf une
image c'est une caricature d'une image
qui était déjà une caricature quand moi
je le faisais c'est le look lepénistes
et jane
avant du coup la liste dans le pénis est
plus grave que
ça s'est passé comment le jour où tu a
rasé sa moustache
oui rien dessous tu aurais préféré avoir
le succès l'argent que tu vas
aujourd'hui ou être le sosie de thierry
lhermitte par exemple
c'est comme ça parce
que je connais tous ses défauts et
thierry
si tu devais très incarnée tu préfères
être incarné ans ou dix allaient nous on
alain delon
sur forteresse épisode mais je ne
promets diront les rôles de jeunes
premiers sont assez chiant à jouer tu
crois que tu vas aller en enfer ou
paradis
je ne sais pas bien mais ce qui me
terrifie c'est que quand je vois les
gens qui sont perçus d'aller au paradis
ça fout un peu les glandes
tous ces gens bien pensants bien honnête
propre ça ça va être terrible en fait
les gens que j'apprécie
ce retour est plutôt un enfer
et
si tu devais mourir ton petit arthur
savez une seule chose à lui dire ça
serait quoi
pas trop de tristesse
je crois que ta caisse à l'heure qu'il
est avec lui oui je vois un
holà c'est mort je prends la tête et
maintenant mesdames et messieurs
j'accueille notre premier invité de la
soirée gérard jugnot
[Musique]
bienvenue au bon soir dont vous avez
déclaré l'acteur est passé du muet au
parlant et du parlant à la promotion là
par exemple sur le film oui mais j'ai
tourné deux semaines et je dois faire
trois ou quatre semaines de promotions
c'est plus long de faire la promotion de
l'éphédrine voilà moins fatigant même
temps c'est à bon ben on va voir ça
dépend des émissions merci gérard jugnot
en arriver là vincent perron
n'a pas eu d'annoncé comment on fait oui
avec lustres
non
bonjour
donc on va faire un petit peu de
promotion le 18 avril sort un film
s'appelle wimbée avait mon anniversaire
mais c'est surtout la sortie de son film
j'ai tué non mais c'est aussi sans doute
pour tourner l'anniversaire doit au
cinéma voilà j'aimerais voir women bien
alors avec vous bien sûr et emilie
puisque vous êtes là c'est surtout
humilité cas emilie dequenne qui est
magnifique c'est son troisième film
après rosetta et le pacte des loups et
c'est emilie dequenne il est excellente
elle se bonifie avec chaque film elle
devient femme en plus nombreux elle
était toute petite quand même réussi à
parler des pédales c'est bien mais elle
est pas encore tout à fait fini c'est ça
qui revient maintenant c'est ça qui est
bien il faut pas prendre ça comme une
choses méchantes non je trouve qu'elle a
à la fois l'état fois très mature et
puis en même temps toute petite fille
c'est vrai qu'elle a elle peut être tout
à fait magnifique et puis tout à fait
ordinaire là tout inde alors continue
bien des gens maintenant on fait ça
[Musique]
alors c'est un film yves lavandier qui
était un script doctors qui veut dire
qu'il répare et un petit peu les les
scénarii des autres et puis là-bas il a
fait son film son premier film il fait
beaucoup de courts métrages avant les
classes le pitch donc c'est églantine
qui est jouée par emilie dequenne qui
est une adolescente de 17 ans qui est
encore vierge 1 elle est sur le point de
c'est vraiment en est là quoi et alors
elle est entourée d'une mère étouffante
d'un père un peu alcoolique d'un père
absent ce qui prend un studio on vit
l'enfant voit bien que ça y est quoi il
prend la tangente le vieux et puis d'un
petit ami qui est très entreprenant
très pressé le voilà donc elle n'est pas
très contente ça se passe pas très bien
là les problèmes de l'adolescence et
pour se libérer tout ça elle décide de
suivre non pas une psychothérapie
compliqué mais une brève thérapie une
brève thérapie elle va voir un psy hors
du commun de cette façon c'est gérard
jugnot et vous appelez l'angine erwan
meneur voulu vous lui faites une petite
thérapie très gentil très sympathique
mais sans prise de tête
oui mais de yb lavandier avec gérard
jugnot emilie dequenne alors le film
aurait dû s'appeler enfin il a failli
s'appeler un ours avec un nez rouge ours
parce que si vous êtes assez
bienveillant à ces nounours quoi aînés
rouge parce que vous faites preuve dans
le film comme dans d'autres d'ailleurs
de beaucoup d'humour un humour
dévastateur entre est très ironique vous
analysez sa vie avec beaucoup de
c'est pas uniquement l'histoire d'une
thérapie d'une aventure humaine de des
milices et aussi il profite yves
lavandier profite de ça pour dépiauter
un peu pour démonter nos jeux
psychologiques dont oui mais c'est un
des jeux comme ça les plus joués sur la
planète oui mais je ferais bien ça je
ferai bien ça mais oui je ferai
j'irai munitions d'ardisson mai
mais il ya ma fille voilà
tout ça quoi non mais c'est très bien
vous êtes un peu le psylle un peu cabot
comme ami will & cabaud je vais bien les
lire la phrase quoi et il a surtout il a
surtout si c'est pour ça que il veut je
crois mal choisi ce qu'il voulait il
voulait que le personnage choix ne soit
pas n'est pas une image traditionnelle
du psy les dialogues sont assez finement
ciselée c'est très bien écrit c'est très
intelligent la phrase clé cdja ce qu'il
faut attendre d'être malade pour aller
mieux et c'est l'autre l'autre point clé
c'est de dire la télécommande a changé
les autres ça marche pas donc il faut
essayer de se changer soi voilà pour
changer toile voilà pour aller mieux
commence par révolutionner la tête avant
de révolutionner le monde voilà alors ça
s'appelle oui mais ça sort le 18 avril
il ya eu notre promo pour vous
vous n'êtes pas venu pour rien
c'est meilleur espoir féminin qui sort
en cassette vidéo en dvd vous savez on
fait un bond ont fait à chaque fois on
fait ça
tu arrêter la grève ça me casse les
couilles
alors c'est l'histoire d'un père
coiffeur à cancale qui est désespéré de
voir sa fille se lancer dans la carrière
cinématographique et c'est un petit peu
autobiographique en même temps non non
non c'est autobiographie on parle de
choses comme ça ouais tu nous touche
mais lorsqu'il est assez marrant c'est
que quand j'ai fait oui mais je tourne
avec emilie dequenne kidon celi à peu
près l'histoire mais il reste par fait
une danse quelqu'un qu'on a trouvé qu'il
ya eu une percée le coût d honneur
formidable et qui est devenue une grande
actrice sauf que les parents d'emilie
sont beaucoup moins tard et voilà que
les miens dans le film bon film papa
vous faites attention à ce que vous
dites pour pas vexé andres et ça non
mais en plus je sais pas serait-ce et
pas je me suis un peu pris le chou avec
mon père mais maintenant ça va très mal
elle d'accepter tout ça pour mettre et
on va en parler
beaucoup du mail me disant thierry moi
j'aimais bien quand tu chantais ma vie
est ce que tu peux leur chanter
pas tout de suite foot les deux vers la
fin d'émission mais pas tout de suite
que j'avais arrêté alors qu'il est né en
1951 dans le 19ème à paris votre grand
père était boucher il a une conduite
héroïque pendant la guerre il a refusé
de faire du marché noir son grand père
donc évidemment la libération et des
pulls clients puisque les pas de viande
1 voilà quand vous dites que vous êtes
nostalgique des des promenades en
brouette avec lui il vous promenez
vraiment dans une boîte où est ce que
vous avez lu ça sonore c'est à lui sinon
j'ai des trucs ils fouillent vous avez
des idées des enquêteurs est ce qu'elle
est devenue
elle est accusée dans le musée bien
non mais c'est vrai c'est pas la
campagne c'est normal de se former dans
des boîtes je vois là tout le monde la
saison comme ça lasse
pas de
changer là dessus oui tu la levrette
qui n'est pas la peine de les voiliers
pour l'une alors pas ce qui me touche ce
grand père ce qui avait à l'époque une
émission qui s'appelle l'homme des voeux
ce parti seul en partie son effectif à
la découpe et la voilà la ronde à la
rondelle on y arrive on y arrive en même
temps son porte monnaie et puis se
promener dans la rue qui raconter des
conneries et quand on dit ah vous êtes
comme des voeux voilà on gagne et je
sens bien et puis si on avait des
capsules en galice en france et mon
grand père qui habitait dans la dans le
loiret à chaud l endroit assez perdu il
y avait aucune raison que le mode et de
passes il avait dans son porte-monnaie
syndicats monsieur le parti seul il n'a
jamais rencontré l'homme dévoué je
trouve ça très peur vous êtes un peu en
paillers avec lui parce que c'est vrai
qu'à un moment tout le monde vous et
votre père est plombier est en fait il
écrivait lui aux gens qu'ils n'ont pas
du tout je suis patron d'une entreprise
de plomberie et c'est vrai ça était
directeur d'une entreprise directeur
d'une entreprise au plan fait attention
à ce qu'on dit andré on fait gaffe non
mais c'est vrai c'est arrivé à beaucoup
de gens qui ont réussi par la suite
quand vous étiez petit vous viviez dans
un lui assez modeste et vous dit j'avais
l'impression d'être un fils de prince
enlevé par des bohémiens si vous n'aviez
pas le sentiment d'appartenir à la
famille dans laquelle vous étiez né tous
les enfants sont comme ça on se prend le
chou avec ses parents dit mais c'est pas
possible c'est presque rien mes parents
sont beaucoup plus intelligents beaucoup
plus compréhensives plus que plus beau
plus riche plus de ce bon c'est des
trucs d'enfants elle s'est dite moi
l'histoire de la lapine plein c'est vrai
mais c'est faux parce que moi j'ai lu
que votre père et votre mère avait reçu
pour leur mariage en cadeau de votre
grand-mère une lapine plein non pas du
tout c'est pas mes parents non mais
pendant cette heure je viens pas
c'est une on s'est connu quelqu'un comme
ça qui qui qui qui me racontait que pour
son mariage on lui avait offert comme
cadeau de mariage une lapine plein voilà
parce que c'était juste après légaliste
est très pauvre enfin mes parents
n'étaient pas pauvre s'était pas point
là quand même si j'étais modeste et ils
sont élevés dans l'échelle sociale ils
sont arrivés à quelque chose de très
bien pour eux comme mes parents voilà
alors vous dit en parlant de vos parents
j'aurais préféré qu'il me donne molière
ou mozart mais finalement ils m'ont
donné la gourmandise et le cholestérol
je te jure ça
l'interview se termine bien parce
qu'après vous êtes réconcilier il ya pas
positif sur andré donc y'a pas de soucis
vous acceptez par mois je parfois
une bonne terrine que fait ma mère
admirablement c'est pas si bon que
mozart c'est vrai qu'à l'adolescence
comme beaucoup d'adolescents vers l'âge
de 18 ans vous étiez très révolté et
vous écriviez sur les murs de votre
chambre on choisit ses amis on choisit
pas sa famille non c'est vrai oui bien
sûr et que tous les enfants tous donné
sans qui on a décrit à tous à toi non
non moi j'avais dépense 1 pas
dû les appeler les thénardier comme
un poisson très sympa non mais c'était
le thème du film que j'ai fait meilleur
c'était de dire voilà tous ces conflits
toute cette incompréhension peut-être si
ça se trouve c'est de l'amour vous êtes
parti de tout le monde n'a pas la chance
d'être né orphelin qui après ça s'est
arrangé le temps aidant on se rend
compte qu'on doit des choses à ses
parents et vous dites aujourd'hui je me
trouve en train de répéter à mon fils
des phrases entières comme disait mon
père et que je trouvais comme à l'époque
oui
et là vous parler que de mon père ma
mère est très important attendez on en
parlait deuxième partie de l'émission
mais ça a eu un intérêt pour vous cette
névrose précoce parce que ça vous a
dirigé vers la création artistique d'une
certaine façon
peut-être qui avait pas eu cette
rébellion contre votre famille peut-être
vous auriez jamais créé ce n'était pas
que contre ma famille c'était contrat
j'avais peur de l'ennui et comme j'étais
un garçon très très timide donc je pense
que
le spectacle c'était une manière de
faire briller un peu tout ça est de
sortir d'avoir des colonnes le faire
partie de ce tout paris qui chante et
qui rit
[Musique]
alors vous commencez par faire un court
métrage qui s'appelle gags aux et c'est
l'histoire d'un type qui va toujours le
côté marrant des choses un lent mais
gago c'est énorme c'est l'histoire d'un
mec qui imaginent une connerie à partir
de chaque chose qu'ils voient non
évidemment c'est de la définition de la
comédie oui c'est une sorte de névrose
comme ça de voir le nom de valverde côté
des choses vis de les transformer comme
ça s'il y avait un enterrement qui
avaient ils essaient de vendre des
farces et attrapes pour le dans cette
église l'aria vesle le calice faveur il
y avait l'hostis élastique il avait le
tabernacle
c'était la grande énergie avec moi les
réseaux sociaux peuvent tous à l'époque
de la tâche d'encre sur la moquette
voilà à une communion j'ai un cousin qui
a mis une fausse merde de chien comme ça
ce très bien imité sur la table et ça
c'est tout et sa formidable l'espèce
d'intrusion début d'une vocation ah oui
ça c'est je crois que c'est ça qui a
fait qui m'a fait ça fait ferrer en a en
tournée il ya quand même
[Applaudissements]
dès l'âge de 14 ans ont commencé à faire
des films alors en super 8
8 à l'époque l'homme fingers c'est une
parodie de goldfinger et assez bien ce
que c'est drôle c'est une comédie g20
gaga c'est pétrifiant où on torturait
avec une lampe à souder brûler les pieds
alors il y avait un plan sur les pieds
ça et puis on remontait et j'avais la
fumée
alors votre vocation prend son élan au
lycée pasteur à neuilly quand vous
rencontrez lhermitte clavier michel
blanc vous écrivez des sketches qui
deviendront les le fonds d'aidé premier
spectacle du splendid en aventures du
splendid en a parlé la semaine dernière
ici avec votre ami thierry lhermitte
j'ai vu là un thierry comment bien
l'armé soffiati retail en fait sont
vraiment e-retail
alors de notre série donc consacré au
roi du rire après thierry lhermitte on a
un gérard jugnot alors nous a parlé de
vous alors là je vais faire magnéto
serge ce que je voulais dire d'abord
c'est qu'effectivement il ya quelqu'un
qui m'envoyait un email en misant j'ai
un chien qui s'appelle magnéto serge et
chaque fois que tu fais magnéto serge le
si un sursaut
donc je suis absolument désolé
à l'époque de deux pasteurs
vous avez des relations homosexuelles et
que gérard jugnot
bah oui il va enfin bouger mais c'est
vrai que récemment que c'est vrai que
récemment vous avez décidé de faire un
petit essai tous les deux à nouveau
ensemble
il veut pas voilà voilà le problème
c'est qu'on peut paraît voilà c'est vrai
je pense qu'il faut rien n'est perdu je
te le dit gérard voix de caméras je te
le dis je suis encore là et je crois je
t'attendrai toute ma vie
[Applaudissements]
d'ermite voilà donc il vous annoncez un
appel
et ça votre père votre père ne le savais
pas non s'est ensuivie une fois au
théâtre
dans un spectacle qu'on vous un numéro 2
de mama
et et d'ailleurs c'était moi l'actif
des formes et la question de l'année la
semaine prochaine c'est la chaîne de la
ligue 1 risque en nutrition se caressait
un en garde voilà
trente ans
alors bon ça
sert votre père ne le savait pas
en revanche quand vous vous lancez dans
la carrière il vous dit est un futur
clochard c'est vrai qu'après le grand
père boucher lui patrons de pme d'un
seul coup ils avaient l'impression que
vous ne continue liepa cette ascension
sociale qui était celle de la famille
jugnot non enfin je crois que la grande
inquiétude mon père qui lui avait
travaillé toute sa vie pour arriver à
une belle situation que l'on dit il
avait peur que moi je travaille toute
l'année pour ne pas avoir de site oui ça
peut arriver vous auriez pu finir à ris
orangis voilà donc c'est vrai que la
première fois que je suis ramené
s'étaient tous hier j'ai amené la fiche
de paye artistes de complément le mot
complément l'anéantît congrès bon
j'avais 20 ans bon ben ça nous ramène
justement un meilleur espoir féminin qui
est un peu un un film autobiographique
comme je disais tout à l'heure alors
continue la promo du film votre père il
a été complètement rassuré parce qu'en
soit vous l'avait invité à dîner avec
michel drucker c'est michel drucker il
sait déchiffrer car je ne sais pas très
bien ce qu'il a appelé
la maison il est tombé sur ma mère
odette
et
attendez je vous ai dit que c'est la
deuxième partie sélection c'est aussi
elle qui m'a donné aussi la force
qu'elle était beaucoup plus positif que
mon père mais est donc ma mère a dit
diane bastien michel drucker nous a
appelés pour nous inviter à dîner il l'a
envoyé chier commanderie qui rappelle
que c'est à dire à michel de rappeler
mon père pour qu'il le croit voilà donc
il était allé dîner avec odette c'était
du dîner aussi odette andrée gérard mimi
toute la bande du moins dans les dîners
et alors là quand il a vu que michel
drucker vous tutoyez là ils le disent et
c'est gagné c'est une espèce d'abonnés
quand il va voir que que je me suis
lancé et écrit que vous moquez de moi
ne prévient pas avec vous tant
entendrait dans les auditions qu'il
s'était l'interview papa maman
le pire est à venir gérard jugnot
le pire est à venir je vous ai concocté
une petite interview pour vous
spécialement voici l'interview alerte
aux roses
[Musique]
lui
voilà laurent baffie ne bouge plus par
le jingle et c'est très bien comme ça
voilà baffie pas bougé alors allons-y le
lieu idéal pour faire l'amour
michel rocard il répondu tout de suite
je pense qu'un lycée escale mieux c'est
ce qu'il a répondu
c'est quelqu'un dans le public chéri des
amis une réputation vous maintenant non
non ce stade région
[Applaudissements]
devient le lieu pour vous il serait
absolument impossible de faire l'amour
je dirais sur un endroit public ouais
autant je t'ai vu une fois
bien alors attention là c'est beaucoup
plus complexe est-ce que vous avez
besoin de faire l'amour pour aimer ou
des mets pour faire l'amour
des mets pour faire l'amour ah bon très
féminin ouais vous pouvez pas faire
l'amour comme ça sans aimer
cette année par cette humiliation
parce que j'avais vu frapper aussi bon
alors voilà non mais attendez c'est un
jeu de l'esprit ça n'a rien à voir avec
leurs épouses de certains jeux de
l'expression je fais est ce que vous
préférez une femme qui baissent bien
mais qu'un fidèle ou une femme qui
baisent mal mais les fidèles
c'est le choix de sophie nord
je préfère une femme fidèle et qui buzze
mal parce qu'on peut toujours à
apprendre voilà on peut lui apprendre
exactement bonnes réponses
michel rocard a répondu aussi peut-être
de ma faute c'est je suis très ami vous
êtes sur la même ligne politique est
est ce que vous préférez qu'elle vous
quitte pour un homme pour une femme sans
café après home away
ne seriez pas moins jaloux si c'était
une femme non je serai interloquée mais
pourquoi pas dans un couple vous
préférez tout se dire oh rien se dire
tu as le droit de faire ça mais non
oui cher c'est tout ça c'est un prime de
2 de moyenne ah ouais demi du doigt
c'est entre les deux sens entre eux tout
se dirait rien savoir mais ouais on peut
dire certaines choses pas tout à fait
d'accord la vérité n'est pas toujours
bonne année en même temps il faut se
dire sur des forces sociales comme tu
ès qu'embrasser s'est trompé ça dépend
ce qui est dans la tronche parce qu'au
cinéma on embrasse d'autres filles oui
mais quand on dit coupe était encore ta
langue dans la bouche
c'est peu ça moi je la change les peu de
salles comme ça alors embrassé s'était
pas trompé voilà c'est
[Rires]
bon dernière question est-ce que sucer
c'est tromper
tu l'as fait aussi
su séoul se faire sucer se faire chez
ces gens là je voulais c'est là parce
que là vous êtes à prendre sympathisé
j'aurais pas
[Applaudissements]
gérable est-ce que se faire sucer c'est
tromper clinton lui par exemple il dit
que non ça dépend par qui a eu d'accord
et j'accueille maintenant gérard jugnot
bonsoir vous êtes ici pour votre
huitième long métrage comme réalisateur
comédien monsieur batignole avec vous
donc comme acteur le petit jules sitruk
michel garcia qui est excellente jean
paul rouve qui est encore plus
excellents qui est vraiment une
révélation enfin dans ce film en tous
les cas et alexia portal voilà ça se
passe pendant l'occupation
c'est l'histoire d'un charcutier
parisien sans grande conscience
politique et qui prend son destin en
pleine gueule à travers l'irruption d'un
enfant juif dans sa vie voilà ça c'est
ce qu'on appelle le pitch c'est à dire
qu'on résume le film en trois phrases en
fait on peut aller un petit peu plus
loin on peut dire qu'on est en juillet
42 dans paris occupé il ya des queues
devant les commerces monsieur batignole
donc les charcutiers il se pose pas de
question et puis un jour tout bascule
ses voisins du dessus les bernstein sont
arrêtés et dénoncés par le beau fils de
monsieur batignole jean paul rouve donc
qui s'appelle l'amour dans le film qui
est imparfait collabos voilà en les
batignolles s'installe dans
l'appartement des bernstein ils vont
chez eux ils s'installent ils se mettent
à leur place et il commence à fricoter
avec les allemands et puis un jour le
petit simon le fils bernstein revient il
sonne à la porte pendant qu'il ya une
fête où il ya l'ailé où il ya les
batignolles et les allemands alors vous
quand vous le voyez vous êtes emmerder
vous avez envie qu'ils s'en aillent tous
comme un chien qui vient gratter à la
porte comme vous dites est ce qu'il
pourrait pas se casser ça serait mieux
puis comme vous voyez ce gosse qui est
là qui est tout à fait touchant vous
décidez de le garder vous décidez de le
cacher vous l'avez vu le film mais vous
êtes sortis de la salle avec les yeux un
petit peu rouge il se mettra que le
masque de fer pour pleurer c'est avec un
coeur sous le coach dit il ça m'a
beaucoup touché non non c'est vrai c'est
très touchant alors là on va s'arrêter
parce que sinon cela recommence
il ya plein de moments forts vents films
notamment le moment où le petit
simon bernstein revient et tape à la
porte et trouve cette fête que c'est
vrai que ce que vous racontez là c'est
nous qui est le fait qu'il pitch
laquelle elle le point de départ cercle
est quelqu'un qui est un petit peu lâche
même dans dans la collaboration savez
c'est pas un très bon collabos sibra et
il est il et il est vraiment faible quoi
au moment où il commence à s'installer
comme ça dans dans la compromission il a
mis son son honneur sur sa danse
approche avec son mouchoir dessus on
sonne à la porte c'est ce petit garçon
qui vient pour être sauvé qui finalement
va le sauver lui même et c'est ça que
j'étais tout à fait de jeu c'est vrai
très joli il ya aussi un moment très
fort c'est vers la fin du film devant un
policier collabos
vous fait passer pour juif quand je dis
ça parce qu'à une scène dans le cas sous
vide dans amen il ya une scène où un
moment ricardo fontana qui est jouée par
mathieu kassovitz et donc à un
ecclésiastique
il est devant le pape et semer une
étoile jaune et c'est très intéressant
de voir que deux films qui sortent au
même moment finalement à un moment ou à
un autre le héros qui n'est pas juif se
met vraiment à la place des juifs on va
vous dire beaucoup de films sur le sujet
en ce moment ben oui je suis le cmc même
mandat la terreur j'en ai marre du sujet
je pars tous les cas moi j'ai vu les
deux je dis aux gens d'aller le voir
parce que c'est pas parce que il ya deux
films sur la même époque qui s'offrent
un temps qu'il faut pas y aller si une
époque intéressante si une époque où
chacun a eu à se déterminer aujourd'hui
je dirais que c'est plus facile à
l'époque voulait savoir de quel côté on
tombait we dance moschino ce qui était
intéressant dans le sujet c'était on a
beaucoup traité ça beaucoup de chinois
j'ai été gavés de ça et j'ai trouvé ça
très passionnant mais c'était peut-être
parler du point de vue de la majorité
silencieuse les 80 % qui n'était pas
informée contrairement à d'autres qui
étaient même désinformer et se dire
voilà c'était l'histoire d'un mec qui à
la fin de la guerre aurait pu dire ben
on ne pourrait pas savoir où ses parents
non là il peut pas dire ce que va dire
je ne savais pas mais pas dire ça c'est
qu'elle est solide à notre époque on
sait beaucoup de choses et on fait pas
non plus grand chose c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque il y avait 10 %
de salles autres collabo
10% de résistants de héros et 80% de la
population qui est un peu comme monsieur
matière le début du film quoi et puis
surtout on était quand même très
troublant batignolles il a cinquante
pays c'est mon âge en quarante deux il a
fait vingt ans plus tôt quatre ans de
guerre contre les poches ben oui il a
fait la guerre de 14 ccp tu as le grand
sauveur de façon tout ça est très
compliqué et très qu'on a essayé de ne
pas être dans le manichéisme d'essayer
surtout de retrouver quelque chose de ce
que devait être cette vie se dire qu'il
ya pas un coup de feu tiré mais il me
semble une grande tension grande
violence et puis surtout il ya aussi de
l'espoir et je crois que c'est ça qui me
plaît c'est d'être là où gérard rassurez
vous c'est un beau film
mais c'est normal il inquiet
on dit que c'est mon meilleur film et
peu de films qui parlent de ça fait par
des non juifs ray est bien vu c'est un
film qui est tout à fait actuelle parce
qu'aujourd'hui en france et une vague de
ta d'antisémitisme au sens où on l'a vu
dans les années 30 mais il ya une
judéophobie certaine je veux dire ne
serait ce qu'à cause de ben laden qui
est devenu une star d une star des
banlieues et c'est vrai qu'on recommence
en france aujourd'hui avoir des étoiles
jaunes peintes sur des magasins dont je
dire ce film finalement n'est pas si
inactuel que ça en tous les cas très
nécessaire compte tenu de oui pour moi
de la tolérance il est aussi les aussi
là et puis mais c'est pas parce qu'on
fait ce film là qu'il faut aussi
accepter ce qui se passe au moyen-orient
on palestine c'est très compliqué tout
ça et c'est un gros bordel quoi alors en
fait le personnage de batignolles est
inspiré par votre grand père même s'il
n'a pas vécu la même histoire disons
qu'au départ le point de départ c'est
votre grand père pp jo quand on écrivait
avec philippe lopez je disais tiens il
ya mon grand père qui était bouché donc
on a fait un charcutier ce témoin les
gaulois par rapport aux petits garçons
verges pas de cochon et puis par rapport
à mon interrogation c'est logique
fondamentale qui et comment un dieu peut
interdire à cesser ces créatures de ne
pas manger de rillettes
c'est un combat qui m'a donné envie
d'aller voir c'est bon alors c'est
marrant parce que chaque fois que gérard
jugnot vient dans cette émission on
parle de son grand père vous êtes né en
1951 dans le 19ème à paris votre grand
père était boucher il a une conduite
héroïque pendant la guerre il a refusé
de faire du marché noir son grand père
donc évidemment la libération et des
pulls clients tu connais pas de viande 1
voilà quand vous dites que vous êtes
nostalgique
des promenades en brouette avec lui il
vous promenez vraiment dans une brouette
ou est ce que vous avez lu ça non c'est
à lui sinon j'ai des trucs ils fouillent
vous avez des idées des enquêteurs non
mais c'est vrai c'est pas la campagne
c'est normal de se promener dans des
boîtes
et
[Applaudissements]
vous avez à faire jouer mon cousin trt
ya combien de temps ça
non ouais voilà c'est ça et alors votre
grand père qui était boucher qui a pas
fait d'affaires pendant la guerre sa
femme le lui reprocher oui c'est ce qui
se passe dans le film là la femme de
batignolles elle est vachement content
d'aller dans l'appartement des berne
chez nous ça fait 200 m² il habite dans
une soupente oui il ya une revanche
sociale ouais et puis bon c'est vrai que
le lait bernstein sont assez aisée et
puis un petit peu pris un peu mais
prison mais c'est aussi ça qui est
intéressant c'est parce que les gens
sont victimes qui sont zéro faute donc
c'était marrant mais si tu es comme jean
paul rouve qui fait jean pierre jean
lamour qui est à carreaux un rôle de 2,2
des grilles de rater deux d'écrivains
raté il même critique raté le faire et
donc je veux
donc je pense que je voulais dire je
suis très fatigué d'abord non
mais je vais continuer lorsque c'est
vrai c'est un film mois que
va très bien il sera presque pas de
promotion que c'est parce que j'aime ce
film je voudrais qu'ils marchent s'il
vous plaît
al avantage de ce film c'est qu'on peut
le voir de nouveau avec la moustache ça
fait une paye que vous n'êtes pas vu
avec cette petite moustache nous sommes
très différentes 1930 soyez toi aussi tu
veux revoir chirurgie de la main stage
sur le
voir monsieur batignole le voilà on y
basque bah ouais c'est vrai c'est assez
clair formidable cette discorde
moustache on parle souvent mais attendez
c'est il a une moustache talent un pull
moustache pas de talent mais il ya un
truc que je savais pas que j'ai appris
en préparant cette interview c'est qu'en
fait vous avez été pendant le service
militaire au contre espionnage
oui non mais ça je ne peux pas en parler
julie signé les papiers contre
un coup au moment du contre-espionnage
faisait partie des gt chauffeur
militaire à la dcn direction de sécurité
militaire là où il y avait les écoutes
moi j'ai un souvenir magnifique d'un
plan comme ça on aurait pu faire il y
avait les mecs qui étaient entre écouter
puis avait à la télé giscard crise et il
n'y a pas d' écoute
c'est tout ce que je peux lire leurs
réseaux que tu faisais quoi j'étais
chauffeur était chauffeur mais d'ores et
déjà la gtoi 6th cgt en civil et comme
j'étais ensuite j'ai mis la moustache
pour passer inaperçu et et on faisait
des filatures on avait des 304 non
filets des mercedes donc pas loin
c'est marrant comment tu m'as déçu
et c'est le compte que ça fait couper
cette moustache pour quel film tandem
dont on n attendait un magnifique film
ci tenait alors vous remarquez qu'on n'a
pas parlé de vos parents ce soir fait
d'habitude on fasse jugnot avec ses
parents sa mère raconte des conneries
ce soir pas d'histoire avec aux dates et
andré picot ce soir à
imiter ma mère avec l'action peignoir
alors qu'elle n'a pas du tout ça c'est
les clichés franco français c'est comme
les mecs qui me disent gad thé marocain
je dis oui python j'adore le couscous
de quoi tu aimes pas
grave
moi moi je dis jamais gérard tu es
français j'adore le camembert et non non
moi je suis parisien rive gauche les
parisiens 2 du nord vous devez survivre
aux quais rive gauche
alors donc on n'a pas parlé de vos
parents là pour l'autre
avec andré sinon on pourrait dire quand
même une chose là une petite chose
autant odette et positiver même naïve un
petit peu on pourrait dire ça ensemble
avec ses hôtes andré les rabat joie mais
c'est vrai mais t'as vous connaissez pas
il me dit un truc à ta mère est comme ça
comme s'il avait passé huit ans avec
n'est pas vrai vous la guerre aux
parents ils ont dîné avec michel drucker
d'accord oui c'est michel qui me l'a dit
soit la bonne monsieur batignole à
ledger signaux bien là
dispo
allez pas me lancer sur drucker je me
dis bien dornach mais voilà je vous dis
où je m'en vais ce sera plus simple
voilà non c'est que vous avez joué vous
retournez votre fiche voilà c'est ça
vous êtes bien précis
j'écris parce qu'il n'ya pas de lunettes
il nous fait que ces écrits grands
noms mais il s'est écrit gros élan plus
là ça vous savez quoi c'est mon côté
génial le père
non mais vous êtes terriblement
pessimiste à cause de venoix je suis pas
payé si si si
je serai que je suis un peu attirés vers
le noir c'est pour ça que je fais des
conneries rires pour que le monsieur qui
vont être insouciant comme toi je tous
les couples vous avez dit par exemple
l'humour c'est comme les essuie glaces
dans la pluie du malheur ouais ça
n'arrête pas là ne viennent plus mais ça
permet d'avancer ça permet d'avancer
bien non moi je trouve ça assez bons il
y en a une autre aussi quelques étoiles
dans ma vie j'ai fait de phrases l'autre
j'ai fait c'est là l'autre c'est vrai le
c'est la vie c'est comme une boule de
flipper il faut pas leur vie ça il faut
faire durer ces camps une gerbille il
faut faire durer la boule le plus
longtemps possible mais on termine dans
le trou oui mais je pense que guy béart
l'a dit aussi
une chance hydrologie guy béart
cardillo j'allais avoir droit il est un
jugement dernier mais avant j'accueille
l'acteur de votre film jean paul rosen
à
j'en trouve
mais jean paul jean paul rouve vous êtes
fc laon dans ce film voilà si et voilà à
quoi vous avez droit
[Musique]
un triomphe romain
à ce prix vous aurez pu faire ça
jean-paul vous restez avec nous mais
d'abord gérard jugnot interview jugement
dernier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa chute gérard jugnot
a dû voler de l'argent dans le
porte-monnaie de ta maman quand tu étais
petit jamais jamais vaincu jamais et pas
l'argent dans porte-monnaie de marrant
ça c'est une chose gérard jugnot
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin dans les cabinets de l'école
malheureusement non au nom masculin
masculin oui
gérard jugnot
têtu tripoter dans les chiottes du lycée
avec des copains en somme et ivey tout
mais par copie
gérard jugnot gérard entrer au paradis
si tu te repent à l'époque dans les
chiottes du lycée avec tes copains y at
il eu pénétration au nom non
d'ordures junior
l'accession enfin écoutés mais tration
seulement
ne dis pas je ne mange pas de ce mandat
si je peux me permettre l'expression
chère art jugnot t'nb
gérard jugnot oui pendant ses vacances à
royan
têtu masturber en pensant à anet
[ __ ] mais qu'on doit il sait pas pas
là mais le
sans doute oui amor amor
gérard
regrettes-tu d'avoir été aussi lourd
dans ce club de vacances en tunisie pour
obtenir de cette malheureuse ta première
pénétration
je me souviens pas
je me souviens pas mon père rousse et
anne et moi
c'est bien mais
regrettent d'avoir été aussi lourd cette
malheureuse j'ai pas été lourd j'étais
léger gérard balance parce qu'elle
attend c'est là des stellistes ou
gérard jugnot
tu as fumé temps premiers pétards aux
usa avec clavier et l'ermite
souhaites-tu la même chose pour ton fils
arthur s'était pas le premier mais c'est
quasiment le dernier parce que j'ai eu
des hallucinations
c'était très fort c'est parce qu'il ya
dedans j'ai vu des mecs avec des canons
sciés sortir des détails et j'ai hurlé
nantes a transformé
je touche pas à ça moi je passe trop
fragile très fragile gérard jugnot
tu n'aimes pas les hallucinations non
non tu as tort
georges in you we had
profiter de ta notoriété pour séduire
pas assez
mais j'avais des sosies qui s'en
servaient à dallas
as-tu déjà profité de sa notoriété pour
demander aux femmes des choses contre
nature
c'est pas osé mais sera du
c'est un peu tard gérard jugnot je fais
une faveur
à texter une migraine pour échapper au
devoir conjugal
non
gérard jugnot as tu déjà fait l'amour
vous sans réel désir de procréer
a tout le temps
gérard jugnot
as tu déjà trompé ta maîtresse
non
monsieur violent mais quoi
mais
bien alors jean paul qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire sauf que peut-être d'être
abonné aux rôles de [ __ ] toute votre
vie maintenant c'est ce que je fais ce
qu'on me dit là je me suis posé la
question en faisant fait tellement bien
le [ __ ] mais vraiment une ordure je
suis une bonne [ __ ] dans la vie des
mamans vous détesterez shamal quoi ça
joue pas mal comme celle des ordures
quoi fait plaisir parce que comme c'est
des jeunes qui montent donc maintenant
il est grillé
ci fais ça que ça s'est passé avec lui
c'est une révélation je suis pas le seul
à le dire
ça crève les yeux j'ai laissé filer
parce que vous avez une avant première
mais et des milliers de gens qui
voulaient attendre l'applaudissant
depuis trois quarts d'heure franchement
ils sont courus si vous dire 10
100 euros d'accord je remercie d'être
venu c'est moi et je vous dit d'aller
voir ce film franchement c'est
formidable j'accueille maintenant
géorgie niaux
[Musique]
sont tous de
mourinho bonsoir bonsoir dont je vous
présente marcela iacub qui est
chercheuse au cnrs jean marie roy
requête académiciens c'est assez odieux
à c'est très haut de gamme eseries et là
en plus ils vont finir ensemble des cinq
est extraordinaire c'est qu'il se sera
penché sont opposés pendant un moment
mais là il commence à parler il est très
bien moi je connais bien jean marie mars
est là depuis des années c'est un garçon
formidable génial pas très fidèle bien
sûr
bien gérard bonsoir vous arrivez du
théâtre vous jouer tous les soirs état
critique de michel la guinée quatre
fontaines oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça se passe bien très bien bah oui parce
que j'ai l'impression qu'après ce qu'ils
voulaient voir gérard jugnot en chair et
en os sur une scène surtout maintenant
il ya les vrais théâtreux qui viennent
quoi oui oui donc j'ai un petit indien
la pièce était pas hésité pas évident de
gagner avec un truc comme ça je joue un
académicien sainte-beuve a été fait fini
académicien et un pistonné par hugo
d'avoir fait qu'aucune n'était pas
rancunier windsor mais non ça c'était
assez difficile à vendre parce que ces
histoires de saintes beurre il ya eu go
on ne voit pas d hugo jugnot tout ça se
mélange s'est ensuivie une pièce en
costume et puis en fait une pièce très
très simple et très belle et très moi
j'avais vu j'ai passé une soirée
délicieuse voilà je le dis c'est rare
que je m'engagerais j'ai trouvé ça comme
vous
non mais c'est vrai alors fait le pitch
tient olala shalalala attention parce
qu'il est académicien et connaissances
bull vrai nom c'est l'histoire de c'est
un salieri de la littérature sébastien
qui s'aperçoit un jour que comme on
s'aperçoit tout ce qui a un type qui est
génial et que nous on est simplement
dans la moyenne pour un type qui à 12
alors qu'au dessus du che au dessus de
lui il ya victor hugo qui casse couille
parce qu'il a va sans travailler alors
donc pour essayer de lui voler un peu de
son talent il va lui voler sa femme
voilà exactement alors le victor hugo je
savais pas jean marie villemin jean que
vous le savez est harcelé sa femme
sexuellement c'est à dire que sam bird
gérard jugnot et en bas avec l ambition
de la drague évidemment du début à la
fin de la pièce et alors on entend des
coups taper comme ça du premier étage et
ça veut dire qu'il en a envie et on y
retourne il a envie victor donc sarah
montand quatrième vitesse abandonnant ce
pauvre samedi c'est une fantaisie
historique mais pas si c'est fondé sur
des sur des faits réels la nuit ne sera
est épouvantable et il s'était retenu
pendant très longtemps il honorait 9 x 9
x ce qui est terrible 9 fois c'est
terrible ouais on connaissait sa vie
sexuelle qui a d'ailleurs été très
longue puisque sa vie d'ailleurs il a
noté dans son journal
la fin de sa vie à chaque fois qu'il
touchait avec une femme dans la journée
il y avait fait d'ailleurs cette fameuse
anecdote c'est utile et il va retrouver
qu'à 65 ans à 70 ans une dame et il
montre au quatrième étage et alors
ils arrivent rôle l'escalier et il y à
vraiment je suis épuisée je vous pourrez
faire courte que trois fois l'amour
non mais c'est un monstre c'est vrai que
c'était un monstre c'est ça qui est
assez joli c'est qu'en fait 109 qui lui
est un personnage qui est un critique
qui qui a qui a très vite il ya une
phrase très belle de zinc qui dit et de
détester de toute son âme parce que sur
l'intelligence le forçait à l'admirer
oui et c'est cette espèce de jeu que je
trouve très beau dans la pièce se salir
et de la littérature c'est quelqu'un qui
est qui qui s'aperçoit qu'il n'a pas le
talent et le génie de ce bonhomme et
donc du coup il va peut-être gagner ce
que hugo n'a pas réussi avec adele s'est
il a gagné en écoute en douceur en temps
réel sur l'allemand il va se faire aimer
c'est donc désormais d'un ver de terre
que je joue mes diplômes mais qui va
être amoureux de l'étoile équivalent à
voir dans la dans la vraie vie là il l'a
eue pendant très longtemps il lui
pendant 6 ans 1 elle est une très belle
histoire d'amour ça alors là il ya
beaucoup de discussions sur cette
question alors là on peut pas dire que
ce neveu avait eu ça aurait fait cette
virilité des années j'étais postale il y
avait des problèmes de graves problèmes
un peu comme qu'est ce qu'il avait
appelé le trou mal placé je crois dans
les votes dans les rangs des données
jalousie sexuelles avec lecture goûtée
peut-être plus grande que la jalousie
littéraire pas pourquoi on vous voit
jamais dans les classiques vous l'avare
le bourgeois gentilhomme tout sauf en
cas d' un beau nom je poussais ces
jeunes ces pièces est belle parce que
elle est un langage un petit peu à la
manière 2 mais elle est très moderne
très s'était créé de nos jours donc il
n'ya pas d'archaïsme les pièces de les
pièces classiques pourquoi pas oui mais
je trouve que j'ai beaucoup c'est
beaucoup d'efforts pour
tout le monde l'a dit parce que si on
postule à quand est ce que vous allez
faire un classique peuvent donc je
pourrais le faire pour moi vous imagine
incarnant la var le bourgeois
gentilhomme d'aidé rôle de louis seigner
un peu ses grands rôles oui pourquoi pas
ces pages vous c'est plus marrant de ces
pièces ont été jouées et rejouées
magnifiquement joué pourquoi aller dans
les terrains qui est resté bloqué oui
ça me fait rire comme moi je vous
demanderai aux juges sinon mais non je
suis pas obligé très franchement il ya
des tas de d'archaïsme dans ses pièces
qu en plus il faut arrêter logement le
molière je me faire beaucoup d'ennemis
et l'état choses formidables l'avare la
fin de la barre c'est consternant c'est
pas il faudrait couper là dedans il
faudrait qu à réadapter je trouve qu'il
faudrait presque écrire mais j'aime pas
les mecs qui font les adaptations en
données non plus en plus maintenant
c'est à craindre le la version maudire
son tout petit c'est le metteur en scène
qui en coin un essai ça n'en suis pas je
supporte bad qui est ce pas mon kiff non
alors quand vous dites gérard jugnot que
j'avais autre chose à faire vous et
bientôt avoir un film à faire c'est à
dire vous allez faire astérix en
hispanie ya c'est à dire qu'après claude
zidi café le premier alain chabat café
le deuxième vous allez faire le
troisième ouais on commence à écrire
vous savez ce que ça va au sein de 36,6
oui
[Musique]
un trio ça ça veut dire ça c'est quand
on est un châssis lh récompense c'est
une récompense
pendant cette émission on est ici peut
être mais moi je suis en train de passer
un peu l'histoire romaine pour ce soir
et ça ça veut dire il peut sortir deux
bouts de blizzard allons vous sortir est
debout des arènes j'espère on va voir si
vous avez potasse est un peu le sujet
comment s'appelle le chef du village
espagnol qui résiste aux romains sous
pas la meilleure écoute one
bravo
[Musique]
double triomphe romain
énorme
alors comme vous appelez gérard vous
appelez bien géré
oui girard je suis le monde sait ce que
ça veut dire gerard guérard fort en
javelot avant lens puissante non ce qui
change beaucoup pendant par les sources
entre eux monsieur arrive donc on va
vers une interview gérable
ce stage vous elle est très gentille ce
soir gérard jugnot oui est ce que vous
êtes content de pouvoir diriger gérard
depardieu dans astérix
c'est pas le mot de diriger est un peu
fort non mais j'adore gérer on s'est
rencontré il ya peu de temps fait on se
connaissait pas bien on a fait veulent
pas nous sommes en c'est tombé dans les
bras on dirige pas de parler on essaye
de le calmer
il faudrait surtout que jean grèce parce
que pour un pays que s'il est un peu
mince alors est-ce que vous pensez que
gérard darmon va avoir le césar du
meilleur second rôle pour astérix
mission cléopâtre
ça je suis assez mal placé pour juger
les césar vu que je me suis fait saquer
sais pas j'espère il était formidable
est ce qu'il le mérite oui et pour
d'autres choses aussi ouais bref un très
bon accueil est-ce que ça me fait de la
peine gérard jugnot de voir que gérard
klein va bientôt arrêter l'instit
mon fou m mais il va pas arrêter si
vous en foutez complètement oui un petit
peu jeune non mais ça a peut-être faire
de la peine à quatre jours mais que
pensez-vous gérard jugnot de l'évolution
des films de gérard krawczyk de l'été en
pente douce jusqu'à taxi 3
et l'emmerdé oui je suis dans la merde
parce que je
regardais ses films un peu moins
personnel
mais bon c'est bien fait
leur avis est ce que vous êtes le vrai
gérard jugnot qu'on vous fait envie mais
je ne veux pas me fâcher avec personne
et je veux inspirer par gérard oury
bah oui qu'il n'est pas dans la comédie
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui qui a
apporté afin qu'ils allaient céder film
épatant et puis moi j'ai tourné avec lui
un film et un peu de temps et je lire
j'ai découvert l'homme l'homme est ainsi
admis rap dans ma part en parlait
beaucoup de peinture beaucoup de
sculptures d'art c'est quelqu'un de très
cultivé moi il m'a beaucoup apporté il a
apporté une chose formidable dans la
comédie c'est qu'il a il a 2 il a donné
des lettres de noblesse il a exigé le
même soin les mêmes budgets parce que
pendant très longtemps la comédie c'est
et considérer comme vraiment un truc à
faire de l'argent mais il fallait pas en
dépenser beaucoup et lui c'est le
premier café kafka exiger des budgets
conséquents pour faire bien ce qu'il
avait envie de faire est-ce que vous
avez des nouvelles de gérard rinaldi des
charlots oui il est venu une nouvelle
fois au théâtre il avait joué une pièce
au splendid et mais c'est un bon acteur
gérard est même cité le dernier film de
gérard lanvin qui est marché
d'assez le boulet ouais ça juste après
ma rupture aussi et gérard sont des très
bons joueurs
c'est
[Musique]
giraille à gérard philipe gérard
depardieu tout à fait alors
est ce que vous croyez que charles
gérard continuera à faire du cinéma si
le loup charette s'est pas son prénom
pour moi c'est un rêve qu'un char donc
je peux est ce que vous connaissez le
frère de polmont vu ça
girard bravo
j'accueille maintenant rihanna karembeu
et jason
français
bonsoir ghana méline tu as des bottins
asi asi aucune différence je lui mets un
peu loin
vous êtes ici tous les deux ce soir pour
un film excellent ce que tu deviennes
habitude chez vous mon cher mon cher
jugnot un gentil non mais c'est vrai la
safa syrie pas mal oui ça marche pas mal
hein ça marche bien là wen ont cédé des
choix là le film de jean yves est un
film différent 1 c'est bien plus un put
âpre mais alors c'est un film s'appelle
trois petites filles de jean loup hubert
effectivement mais d'abord il faut quand
même qu'on rendre hommage à gérard
jugnot pour les choristes
c'est ça ouais là chaque fois oui non
non
mais je sais pour astérix film c'est
parfait donc ré maintenant je me méfie
des hommages là ça y est c'est fait
c'est fait bien fait c'est vrai qu'avant
les avants les corrigent des teens
vedette maintenant vous êtes une star
c'est bien triste
gt gt poulidor je suis un plan de 10
8 millions d'entrées quand même à mal
par semaine
et non seulement c'est un succès
hexagonal mais ça va être un succès
mondial parce que les canadiens ont
trouvé ça formidable miramax adore le
film est sélectionné par la france pour
les oscars c'est génial on normalement
que ça marche à singapour partout non
c'est fou c'est faux c'est fou j'ai rien
à dire c'est fou c'est génial oui il
faut dire aussi qu'en monsieur batignole
passées à tes l'évidence ça fait douze
ennemis millions de téléspectateurs je
suis vachement content voici la
meilleure audience d'un film à la
télévision sur tf1 depuis 1998 quand
même
que dire de
vue à regus tcg gus voilà une ravie je
viens la télé maintenant que tu es tout
le temps avec adriana karembeu ça c'est
très bien aussi il transcende toute la
journée juste
sur top des grandes idées
non ce qui me fait très plaisir c'est
que c'était pas des films attendus en
tout cas les choristes personne ne
croyait à succès en tout cas pas ce
magot et donc ça fait rêver tout le
monde parce que du coup il ya des tables
sim qui devait pas se faire qui sont
même ce film là pour moi j'ai pas un
grand rôle mécanique un très beau film
il ya une il ya une lumière plus grande
qui se pose de se financer c'est
agréable le succès aussi ouais en tous
les cas vos films marchent quoi qu'on en
dise voilà le cas c'est pas le cas de
tout le monde oui prenons au hasard
tu l'as mérité un petit t-shirt arrêt
pour frimer dans le métier voilà
merci
[Applaudissements]
messieurs
restons dans le prêt-à-porter adriana
j'ai pensé à d'offrir une petite jupe
[Rires]
voilà c'est un petit cadeau à ceux qui
l'ignorent
représentent-ils pas cela parce qu'on se
rend pas bien compte que c'est joli
puisqu'on vit n'ont jamais vu c'est la
collection jamais vulgaire donc c'est
une énorme série dans les bronzés 3 vous
avez exigé d'être celui qui héberge le
plus c'est vrai
et remixeur et dimitri
oui les autres sont au chaud
non ils veulent tout couché avec vous
qu'est ce que c'est à cannes a fait ça
fait que toutes les femmes soit sur vous
comme ça et c'est toujours été comme ça
je le disais moi mais quand vous êtes à
la fiche tous les deux de trois petites
filles de jean loup hubert ils nous ont
bien traités sur le film très bien ouais
c'est bien carlos j'avais une
disposition quand même france est
partagée avec
faut partager partager avec gérard on
est tous pareils c'était très bien de
moi je fournis et tu peux pas faire pipi
n'y avait pas de tous les temps c'était
très dur ça très rock'n'roll mais après
pendant deux mois l année dans la règle
dans la garrigue enfin dans le maquis
mais il y avait des trappes elle est là
la paix des châtaignes tu n'y fait
attention ça peut faire vaincre au
il y avait des petits cochons
c'est une fille toute simple ouais ça
c'est
hélas hélas il a eu cette idée de ma
roue d'engager des sens avec dans son
film la gestion parce qu'il m'a vu un
sur votre plateau de télé qui jean loup
mais non c'est vrai c'est vrai mais le
nombre de gonzesse qui sont choisis
croyable et nous rien on stagne toujours
la personne n'appelle jamais personne ne
veut de nous c'est lamentable mais le
rythme de la promotion ce moment c'est
pas trop dur nos habitudes et ça c'est
vrai c'est lourd c'est du rhin
personne hormis c'est terrible parce
qu'il faut sourire être de bonne humeur
dire que le film est bien que l'équipe
était géniale est tous là c'était grande
famille mais on parlera de crime qui est
très très très très beau
savoir être plus facile quand les films
sont bien accueillis tu vas me sont de
qualité
jean-louis il a fait un vrai beau film
qui parle de choses vraiment qu'ils
peuvent toucher gens il ya des gens qui
sortent tout à fait bouleversé par le
film vous avez une fille non non mais
j'ai adoré le film s'il a deux fils à
laver il a oublié déjà ah oui c'est vrai
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est adriana il
est pas trop entreprenant avec vous un
jugnot n'ont pas ces sons doux ouais
ouais ça joue ça c'est au sonar elle
était géniale pendant pendant le
tournage vraiment grâce à lui j'ai été
vraiment à l'aise il m'a fait beaucoup
rire m'a donné beaucoup de conseils j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour toi et merci
encore
à tous vous embrasser la langue
[Musique]
oui j'aurais plus parce qu'ils ne
savaient pas allé comme on faire d ici
les magies possible comme dans la vie on
a très bien pu tu vas essayer vous
remettez pas la langue au cinéma enfin
voila tu es assez honnête à sun j'aurais
pu un tu m'as dit que tu sais toi qui
l'a jamais fait
tous voulaient remettre bas non non pas
forcément mais
mais bon non mais c'est vrai que c'était
assez bizarre quand même pour moi on va
c'est quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas assez
ça nous arrive pas tous les jours
j'avais un nom je sais pas c'était
étrange non
c'est un métier
là c'est sûr que c'était moi quand elle
jean lou m'a dit voilà je vais te parie
adrien qui a pu tomber par terre son ca
et c'est très amusant ce métier bon il
n'ya pas que ça c'est aussi aussi
terrible deuil aurez beau jour tu vas
tuer jean rochefort dans ce film va
violer jacqueline maillan bon c'est
quand on joue et qu'adriana on doit être
obligé de rentrer le ventre toute la
journée non
on va maintenant maintenant on va passer
à la promotion du film adriana d'accord
donc c'est un film qui s'appelle trois
petites filles de jean loup hubert
sortie le 29 septembre avec vous deux
morgane cabot sabrina ouazani et lucie
de saint thibault alors je fais le pichu
vous le faites les gens lui on va voir
donc ces trois ados dont une est
d'origine algérienne est en pleine
révolte parce que sa famille veut
retourner vivre en algérie et la mariée
de force avec son cousin alors pour
éviter ça les trois ados décide de
contacter johnny depp et vanessa paradis
et de les convaincre d'intervenir dans
les médias voilà alors la presse people
annonce vanessa paradis et johnny depp
en corse donc les trois gamines partent
en corse et là elle rencontre le couple
que vous formez tous les deux vous vous
êtes gogo danseuse et vous vaguement
imprésario oui
genre de comme ça des animateurs qui l'a
rencontré cette femme et qu'il a fait
travailler quoi c'est un petit petites
entreprises à 2 ouais voilà trois
univers
en septembre elle vient
ils sont nos invités ce soir une scène
d'anthologie c'est le soir de la soie de
la rencontre là quand vous dansez dans
la boîte c'est
génial fait ça très bien dire que vous
avez fait ça tous de vie
merci pour le compliment moi je me suis
entraîné un tout petit peu c'est vrai
que là c'est quand on voit pas c'est
bien jean loup voulais juste injustement
montré la mairie garde vers un verre par
là alors on voit pas tout la salle mais
une scène très bien aussi parce que ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que vous vous
envoyer plein de mecs dans le film donc
les trois petites elles pensent que vous
êtes une [ __ ] et glissez votre mac est
en fait un soir sur la plage pour
expliquer que non c'est parce que vous
aimez ça c'est un peu comme les bonbons
quoi mangeuse d'hommes ouais tu savais
qu'en ce moment de leur mandat comme les
régimes moi je suis copropriétaire ouais
mais parlons il même en tant qu'elle est
capable de me pardonner de m'accepter
comme je suis que tu crois
une scène d'amour elle te met les
menottes en fourrure rose que très bien
placé il ya deux visions des sommes
assez terrible on n'en sort pas très
grand dit du film et surtout avec l 1
très beau compliment sur vous il a dit
c'est une actrice débutante bien sûr
mais c'est pas un mannequin qui joue la
comédie
c'était difficile de qu'elle accepte ça
je trouve ça très courageux parce que
c'est vrai que pour une fois on
s'intéresse pas que à sa plastique comme
un bleu dans ses émissions ce n'est pas
qu'un jambon c'est aussi un esprit à une
usine à il sait parler aux femmes
orientales de la charcuterie ces faits
batignolles d'un constat
non mais c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui a
une très belle âme est qui et qui est
une actrice débutante mais qui qui
débute bien avec beaucoup de sincérité
je pense qu'elle est comme les petites
filles qui sont aussi d un pré débutants
et il s'est donc un film s'appellerait
quatre pros petite fille plus une grande
comme christian karembeu l'a accepté
facilement que vous fassiez facilement
parce que parce que san antonio voilà
six arrêtés lhermitte à tilleur être un
caca nerveux
non ça presque pousse l affaire parce
que le scénario 1 plus énormément ben il
a lui aussi ce que ce que j'avais
auparavant et puis c'est là il m'a dit
vas-y essais on va voir qu'est ce que ça
donne sa première fois vous partez aussi
longtemps de la maison 45 jours celle
points selon ce que j'ai l'habitude de
travailler travailler et rentrer chez
moi chez moi c'est vraiment où je me
repose je respire c'est
découvrir ce que c'est maintenant tous
les acteurs ont ce problème là il est
venu me voir arriver venu oui c'est ce
désert je n'ai pas rencontré non je ne
connais pas attention ah oui ça
j'entendais parler riche
tous les chiens et christiane hingrez
et david ta femme elle te suis en
tournée pour l'instant j'y suis pas
retourné mais va me suivre elle va de
suivre toutes les dates tout peut-être
non non sans avoir ni le petit là
bientôt un garde 60 ans comme moi deux
filles et un garçon
ouais mais dit taylor n'est pas moi je
dis pas toujours la vérité en face non
mais j'ai vu que j'avais 6 ans vous êtes
marié avec question un
neuvième année comme ensemble
pour ma page c'est pas hyper un premier
jour je serai un peu pourri aussi tu vas
pas changer quoi non pas parce que la
première fois que si vous disiez que
vous faisais l'amour trois fois par jour
c'est toujours le cas jamais d'issarbe
aussi non
non deux fois j'ai jamais parlé de ça
une fois ce n'est
pas trop dur de rester fidèles quand
même un sérieux pour moi mouais pas du
tout un bon appareil tombe avec gérard
très envie de craquer parfois j'ai pensé
un peu mais on n'est pas du tout
compatible ça marche est partie j'ai
pris une petite voiture il faudrait
acheter un kangoo
petit fils de jean louis meurt
c'est le temps
[Musique]
c'est
alors gérard jugnot gérard jugnot comme
vous êtes un monstre sacré du cinéma
désormais on va vous faire une interview
qui a été écrite par un monstre sacré de
la littérature
marcel proust connais pas mais avant
pour compliquer les choses
les mariachis
[Musique]
interview brouzes mariette si
elle a débuté médias mardi
on a débuté à chaque café à
paris et à partir de minuit commencé à
jouer jouer très bons amis
pour vous le comble de la nuit
on est mariés vous
ou alors il libre
sa valeur ok vous
ful
talât
l'orgueil pareil
robert c
favori le grand ferrer
si tout va
à ce que vous détestez par dessus tout
un
la part les mariachis
janvier c'est tout
comment auriez-vous mourir voir
mais pas
cette impression de votre esprit
ce retrait
allegrini
tu veux
à 12 heures
oh
[Musique]
mélanie doutey gérard jugnot
c'est beaucoup la wii c'est beaucoup en
temps c'est mérité
en tout cas ça fait plaisir pour
l'adapter sur la dernière fois vous êtes
venu gérard jugnot vous étiez accompagné
d'adriana karembeu
se sont pas présentés est ce que vous
seriez le nouveau séducteur du cinéma
français
plus connus on fonce dessus oui c'est
vrai vous connaissez pas papa maman bien
sûr été dans le métier absolument tu
sais dans ce métier ça n'empêche rien
on est ici ce soir pour un film adapté
d'une pièce de musset il ne faut jurer
de rien c'était un film d'eric si wagnon
avec vous deux et jean dujardin qui sort
mercredi prochain le 28 septembre voilà
le classent le pitch un bébé oui
quand même bien vous faites si bien donc
gérard est un riche commerçant jean
dujardin son neveu mène une vie dissolue
l'alcool les femmes le jeu sur le compte
de son oncle
c'est là que vous gerin décidé de le
marier à mélanie qui est issu d'une
famille aristocratique mais qui roule
pas sur l'or parce que vous voulez
ajouter à votre fortune quelques titres
de noblesse mais jean dujardin votre
neveu n'a aucune envie de se marier et
ils parient qu'il peut facilement
séduire mélanie en 24 heures est donc
prouvé qu'elle ne mérite pas d'être aimé
mais mélanie croit à l'amour et vous
allez vous révéler beaucoup plus
difficile à conquérir que prévu se
rendra au début oui voilà
c'est formidable c'est fini parce qu'il
ya un mot par fish
samu
ça lui permet le lundi le directeur ce
week end a fait 400 fiches
voilà c'est vrai nom mais vous n'hésitez
pas à aller à l'encontre de ce que vous
demande votre mère en fait vous refusez
de vous laisser séduire facilement parce
ce jean dujardin voilà surtout cécile
est un personnage qui est qui a envie
d'aimer la personne afin de choisir la
personne qu'elle va aimer quoi est donc
là on sent qu'on essaye de les imposer
quelqu'un et c'est ce qu'elle redoute le
plus donc ce qui était très moderne pour
l'époque quoi c'est même un peu
féministe un peu féministe elle
revendique de choisir sa vie c'est un
peu george sand c'est pareil c'est ça
d'ailleurs normal c'est beyoncé au mcdo
c'est une
filiation elle dit une phrase
souvenez-vous comme que tout en haut du
corps d'une femme îlienne tête ah oui
pour les gens qui pensent comme ça
non mais c'est vrai que là on est en
train de parler sûr sûr sûr des choses
ça c'est grave ce qui m'a nous plaît
dans deux films mais en plus cela j'ai
eu parce que j'ai toujours un peu en
province voire écouter les salles on a
vraiment les gens sortent avec la banane
il vient comme ça qu'est ce qu'ils
savent pas trop ce qu'ils vont voir et
puis sortent vraiment très heureux parce
que les costumes les carrosses d'être
moi je vais le voir ce film
un côté cartouches un peu il ya un côté
fanfan la tulipe qu'est ce que t'es
ridicule il ya des odeurs que la fête
commence
absolument mais on avait un petit peu en
verve a toujours peur du film en
costumes franco tous les films son
costume à cet e3 pour quelqu'un utilise
mes jetons corps au contraire c'est une
magie s'ajoute une magie et un plaisir
de une beauté le thème du film c'est
l'impossibilité de s'engager en amont
c'est très actuels comme thème nos
traditions
oui en effet en effet voilà
déjà pour lacan il qu'un soupçonné oui
je crois que oui
c'est pas ton rire à toi tu
es là rires très particulier quand je
sais pas quoi vous répondre en fait
parce que oui oui c'est très c'est très
moderne c'est très actuelles etc des
thèmes intemporels donc on en entendra
encore parler en se questionnant encore
dessus pendant très longtemps c'est moi
j'ai passé quelques fiches là parce que
je vais gérer
quatre mots d'un coup bravo
j'en avais une imbécile mais je vous la
pose qu'on allait si on est habitué
gérard
gérard belle fille m'a dit ça il a
applaudi les applaudissent aussi c'est
dur d mais à notre époque pain répondait
pendant ce temps je regarde un peu où
j'en suis
non c'est pas dur c'est difficile
parfois mais c'est vrai que la
difficulté c'est de faire durer
s'est bien passé
tu as raison parce que des fois ça se
passe pas bien les bonnes questions vous
êtes bien entendu avec dujardin ouais
c'est plus facile de jouer au théâtre
c'est quoi votre personnage quand on
joue avec une fille comme mélanie est ce
qu'on rende son ventre avant les scènes
je passe vous avez remarqué mais voilà
j'ai quand même perdu puisque j'ai vous
défouler un volet à ses chemises rayées
il photos volées on a émis un
greffé inventera faut vanter mais
c'était mon ventre donc j'ai commencé
j'ai perdu vous êtes bien voilà ça vous
plaît une autre question mélanie quand
vous êtes venus j'étais très gentil avec
vous oui il déclaré à un journal thierry
est très gentil avec moi j'aimerais le
revoir en dehors de la télévision
alors quand
alors que moi j'ai pas trop envie de
faire interview mais ils ont peu trop
envie de faire la promo non plus non
mais ce qu'on est obligé de parler du
film dont on a parlé on a vu l'abandon
ce qui est très bien qu'il donne envie
voilà bon et je vous avez quelque chose
à ajouter pour qu'on allait voir ses
filles
s'il faut aller voir ce film parce que
tout je trouve qu on re découvre par
exemple gérard dans un rôle complètement
surprenant où il est où il arriva il
dégage une énergie dans son côté très
obsessionnel par l'argent en fait on
découvre que c'est un homme qui est
malheureux qui a qu'une envie c'est
d'être à nouveau heureux gens aussi pas
de son personnage valentin parce que
c'est le chevalier moderne parce qu'ils
nous rappellent belmondo parce qu'il est
complètement extravagant qui est
chevaleresque et romantique à souhait
parce qu'il ya
dessus parce qu'il ya ait pas là parce
que c'est une très belle histoire voilà
qu'il faut aller voir et c'est très joli
c'est très rythmé voilà
voilà il ne faut jurer de rien sortie le
28 septembre
et sachez le making of sur papier c'est
aux éditions mendes et messieurs les
corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux